you're an amazing person Nelly I
couldn't ask for a more incredible
daughter
actually trying to parent me right now
who would want me to be a part of their
life a big reason I never made this film
was because I couldn't cast it and then
I stumbled on Brendan immediately a
light bulb went off
I had no idea how he was going to play
Charlie I just felt it was the right
thing I think Charlie is the most
emotionally demanding character I've
ever seen on paper I had to walk the
tightrope moment to moment
[Music]
mom don't freak out shut up Charlie has
been visited by his daughter Ellie
they're interrupted when Charlie's
ex-wife Mary arrives with Liz
how he told you she was coming over no I
did and just in time looks like Ellie
how much money did he offer you the lid
has been blown off of his plan to gift
money to his daughter Charlie who could
have gotten you anything you needed
special beds physical therapists [__]
health insurance it's an interesting
scene as a director to take on Mom
you're not getting any of my money or
shut up Howie leave right now
wait
Ellie I know you didn't mean to hurt me
I know this is me listen I don't care
about you get that through your [__]
skull Billy please just [__] die
already
Ellie has just blown out of there and
she's kind of declared to him like I
don't care about you like it's kind of
the darkest moment between the two of
them and Mary is her last life preserver
and so I think Charlie knows that
you're wheezing
you let me hear
was two characters who hadn't seen each
other for a long time who of course
loved each other for a long time who
fell apart and then they come back
together in the scene
there's something very personal he was
constantly bringing every day
was little
we took that trip
Ellie played in the sand and we lay down
on the beach
you said for days after that I smelled
like sea water binary
[Music]
I'm sorry
[__] you
for sure
[Music]
listen to me
I need to make certain that she's gonna
be okay
can't give up on her you already gave up
on her you gave up on her when she was
eight years old I wish I could have been
a part of her life it's a very very
pivotal scene it's the only scene that
has Mary in it there is so much history
and hurt because he's trying to make
sure that his daughter is going to be
okayed a part of both of your lives go
to the hospital if you'll notice like
the camera stops moving when an actor
stops moving it was a moving sculpture
at all times the simple blocking of it
all everything needed to be concise even
down to the way that Charlie's feet
Propel him forward with one foot a
bladed in is indicative of the pain that
he's in that his legs just aren't strong
enough in spite of that he's still
trying his best to come closer to her
he's going to her for the first time I
need to know that she cares about people
and other people care about her
and she's gonna
be I need to hurry
have anyone
anyone need to know
the day right with my life
[Music]
those played out parts
I raised her
and you're giving her the money
it's the best we could do I remember the
day that we shot that very pivotal line
and I was just bowled over you can see
it in that take what you're doing with
your eyes is just incredible do you need
anything
before I leave
water or something
as soon as he did the first take I
realized that the camera was completely
on the wrong side of the line here was
an actor who was just about to release
all of this emotion and that unless I
got around to capture it the camera was
all set up the lights were this way even
though it's going to cost us all this
time I don't want
um Brendan to to lose whatever he's
tapping right now I wanted to make sure
the camera was in the right place so we
made the hard decision we sealed up the
wall we moved the camera to the other
side we had everyone take a break and
just relax for a second and two three
takes later on the other side that
that's what Brendan did and it was just
this incredible incredible thing to to
be a witness of working with Adrian and
working with those effects in this movie
we had to sit there with Incredible
eagle eyes to make sure that it felt
real in between takes there was just an
endless barrage of work on Brendan who's
being pinched and prodded and moved and
fussed about to kind of hold on to his
emotion Prosthetics and face limits
facial expressions and with Brandon it
was imperative that that wasn't the case
the weight that went into creating
I truly needed makeup to become Charlie
it was an incredibly
difficult
role to play not just because of wearing
those Prosthetics every day four hours
in one hour out
he was working five hours a day more
than everyone else and also just how do
you
save your energy to do the second
hardest part of that role which is all
of the different emotions and you could
see even the scene there's anger there's
defensiveness there's pleading and then
almost begging at the very end through
just a complete confession of his
failures as a person and his wishes just
to just to do one thing right Darren was
insisting of having something that was
as true and authentic as possible
something that would be respectful and
the way it was designed but also
something that would be helping Brandon
and and creating the character we're
going to see Charlie in Decline the
makeup has been changed his health is
great it's makeup also degrades how easy
is it to move
you had to maintain such a consistency
of an emotional through line through
this very long very complicated scene
over the process of many days
do you ever get the feeling
capable of not carrying
[Music]
people are amazing